great everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel and today you wouldn't want
to be talking about my January
highlights which is actually only two
things this time it's Resident Evil 7
and the Nintendo switch stream which we
got just a couple of weeks ago now but
it did contain some exciting stuff but
the Nintendo switch but I'm still not
going to pre-order it so I guess that's
a good place to start
honestly in the shortest times the
reason that I'm not getting the switch
on day one is because I can't justify
the price if it were maybe a hundred and
fifty dollars which I to be honest never
expected I thought it would be 250 then
maybe I would order the switch and get
it day one as bizarre as the
presentation was the idea that you can
feel a ton of stuff in the joy clan
controllers and that they have like some
sense of range is super impressive to me
but as it stands right now with the
launch lineup I'm definitely going to be
getting Zelda on Wii you rub that on
switch and I'm kind of thinking that
maybe I'll buy the switch when Mario
ought to see comes out because that
looks [ __ ] amazing but I am
definitely a supporter of the switch in
general and then you know thinking about
what it is is a portable tablet that
assuming it has Virtual Console we don't
even know yet which in itself is
infuriating it acts as kind of a portal
to the last like 20 years of games that
I've loved in my life and I know a lot
of people are talking about third-party
support but I feel like a very small
amount of people care about that when it
actually comes to buying the Nintendo
switch themselves I don't need another
console that's gonna play third-party
games when I already have access to a
ps4 and Xbox one and a PC but that said
even after the recent conference
I still have loads of questions about
the switch and I feel like that's bad
communication on that pilot what the
hell is the online infrastructure going
to be they told us that you had to pay
for it but they didn't tell us any of
the services they were offering they
said that there was going to be some
kind of an app but we don't really know
what that app involves how much is it
going to cost how a friendslist don't
look are we finally going to be able to
use one account on multiple different
Nintendo devices like if I break my
switch can I transfer my account to
another switch device and maybe access
previous purchases or Virtual Console
purchases with that device so I don't
have to buy the same game for the fifth
time we don't know much about the UI and
I just really want [ __ ] know and
Metroid is so still a ton of questions
but overall I don't have a reason to buy
one yet
and that's said I would have felt the
same way about the Xbox one and the ps4
on launch so let's move on to Resident
Evil 7 oh my god I've played about four
hours of Resident Evil 7 and because I
played it at a press event that doesn't
actually include the first hour now
based on all of the trailers and the
demos that they've shown publicly
Resident Evil 7 looks like out lost I
tweeted that I said before I had played
it that I thought that it didn't look
like Resident Evil and it's just a win
marketing choice I was wrong
it's still about finding objects or
finding weird keys that align with
certain doors or there's a weight puzzle
where you need to put something on
something to take something else off
there are safe rooms and there's an
inventory management and you have other
powered weapons but still feel like you
have no power it is so much more like
Resident Evil 1 & 2 than it is like the
lady games in the franchise some of the
boss fights really stressed me out
pretty intensely but it isn't the
outlast Silent Hill thing that it looks
like from the trailers that we've seen I
promise you and even though it has this
kind of Texas Chainsaw Massacre vibe and
it's on some kind of plantation you
aren't being chased constantly there's
loads of weird very quirky Resident Evil
style downtime outside of that has
really not a lot of media I can trim
engineering I'm still playing Final
Fantasy 15 I just can't stop playing
Final Fantasy 15 but I do have to thank
the people who supported my channel in
the past couple of weeks one of those is
dark zone be gaming show who said pretty
cool thanks man we have Mike NIT Roy
theory of pandas Michael crows a Osiris
Liara and Johnny Boz also Damon Boyce
who left a really long message I have to
mention that sometimes if you leave a
particularly long message on YouTube it
automatically gets flagged as spam so I
didn't see this one until just today but
David thank you so so much
I will send you a message as soon as I
can on the Twitter account that you
listed so thank you guys thank you guys
so so much for watching I will see you
next time